hello ladies and gentlemen
so I'm going to chase you through the
new ideas of Silicon Valley and you know
cradled in Palo Alto and some of these
ideas are you know probably improbable
for now but we have a sort of a history
of making some of them probable after a
while so that's why I called my
presentation 30 things you will hear
today but may probably only believe
tomorrow and why well because we are
basically it's a very computation
intensive environment of Palo Alto and
because we are basically you know our
our company is sitting between the three
other startups Stanford University
Google and Facebook and Apple then and
so we come to we come together like
almost weekly talking about new ideas
some of them are not only mathematical
and computational so philosophical and
so sometimes we are visited by DC people
you know - for regulation and it's a
really a great you know environment to
live I moved my family in 2010 to
Silicon Valley and I'm very happy that I
did so just before I start my waiver
went off so nothing I say here can be
construed as as a investment advice so
so first of all number one I believe
that so we set up the company in 2016
with a very clear mission as
computational as computer scientists and
so I are worked you know for quite a
while I've been exposed to MIT how we
set up teams and how we basically make
computer scientists and so you see an IT
person and a computer scientist is
actually now a very different breed
people don't realize it yet but so I
sometimes have to say that when we hire
a new doctor in the in our team that we
do not fill the paper tray of the fax
machine but UCD what we have done in in
and as an advancement in computational
science with algorithms is actually
quite fascinating so why will I will I
think that more and more computer
scientist groups will get into biotech
because it's a lot easier than from
biotech to go into computer science
that's what we think because basically
it's all about formats you know we are
used to work with encrypted and
mathematical data every day so if it is
Jason fast Q or BAM files we don't care
so we make ontology z' we make parsers
we make the formal grammars we make the
compilers so and so you you have here
the motto of MIT which according to the
administration means that the Institute
has the finest professors but actually
it means I have the freaking power you
know and so what when we approach the
industry and certainly the payers and
the pharma said this is a marriage made
in in in heaven because you have the
freakin data you know let's work
together so I believed more and more
units of computer scientists will
actually go into biotech and especially
computational biology and just to give
you an idea what that would mean you
know so this is ICML 2019 so we don't go
to any biological or medical conference
because mostly to computer science
conferences because we want to stimulate
more computer scientists to go into
medicine and to go into bioinformatics
and computational biology so if you see
what we're presenting there you know
like mapping high-throughput to DNA
sequencing with learned index structures
all these things like it would never
come from a biotech company so we frame
every problem as a learning problem and
we generalize that through the machine
now did you know that and we actually
the industry that knows most about AI
and how AI impacts actually a new
industry is the military industry so the
US Army has been very early in the field
you know after the Department of Defense
adopted Wernher von Braun after the war
and so we were able to have our first
spy planes we used it in in the Vietnam
War
but of course they were not combat
vehicles so the unmanned combat aerial
vehicles came from the 80s which was
actually also early so we have now 40
years of experience now how this has
actually changed the army so first of
all we give you an example
so the normal jet jet pilots they do
like 200 hours but an unmanned aerial
combat pilot does 1200 hours 600 percent
increase we cannot hire you know enough
pilots for pilotless drones also the
overhead per fighter per pilot you know
is 110 data scientists because we have
to ingest all that data science and
actually put it back into the machine so
that the machine learns and we have been
extremely good at that
well I mean not we I mean the Department
of Defense has been extremely good at
that
because you know
they are now on to microseconds and on
to millimeters for the delivery of
weapons I mean for you know a Hellfire
missile coming from a predator it's sort
of the Amazon Prime of death you know so
what is the the conclusion for this well
I'm sure that every doctor will actually
create a hundred jobs because the same
will happen in medicine and every job
will create more patients and healthcare
will become a continuous function and I
would like to explain the difference
between a discrete function or
continuous function because it has
changed the the battlefield it has
changed the army and it will also change
medicine so a discrete function is like
your bank account you put money and you
take money out so you're very reactive a
continuous function only has two
singularities you born and you die so
it's a growth function so this means for
the army there is no longer war but
there is also no longer peace there is
something like you know a bipolar entity
war peace where we continuously and
incrementally do the learning of peace
and war at the same time I think the
same will go for medicine and that with
the introduction of data science so we
will not be sick anymore but we will
also never be healthy anymore so we will
be sort of sick healthy all the time
another thing that so we have calculated
pretty well is hyper scalars and extra
scalars and I would you know I'm you
know you know manifest destiny better
than then I do I am NOT born in this
country but in Europe we had something
like it it was called Lebensraum it
means the natural you know the natural
development of an idea must have the
place to evolve
itself now data you know just as
manifest destiny was a mission from God
to take the North American continent
data also has a mission and we don't
know where all that data is going to be
located because for the moment we are at
the you know when you look at big data
we are at an exabyte you know at source
sorry several exabytes we don't have
enough data all over the world data
centers all over the world to put all
that data in there so 80% of all the
data centers which is 500 data centers
are controlled by 24 companies who are
frenetically trying to build more data
centers now the power law that exists on
medical data which was actually issued
by IBM and surprisingly was right so
that is every 73 days medical data you
know will double so this doesn't mean
that it doubles five times a year it
doubles two to the fifth to the 32 times
32 times a year you know 36 times a year
it doubles you know like that means we
are going to go in 2020 for the
satellite and we certainly don't have
the room for this so you know that there
have been speculations that some states
in the united states like West Virginia
perhaps should become data centers and
people will then live in a data center
everyone would have a job and the sort
of would merge with the data and it
would be very happy
so Alabama is also New Mexico is on the
list so it would actually decrease the
debt level of the federal government and
by 2024 on the yottabytes that would be
that a complete planet is actually one
computer and everything is data so on
the other hand you have access scalers
what is an exascale or an exascale er is
not about big data it's about big data
in the real time so our brain functions
as an exaflop that's a billion billion
calculations per second floating points
so we will reach that in 2021 it's a
race going on between the Department of
Defense she called a supercomputer or
hora and the Chinese supercomputer I
forgot the name but I don't think they
were with so and it's by 2021 we will
produce actually the first excess scalar
so for all this data the you know the
first of all the superpower plus on the
other hand the super storage for the
moment we have no idea how this is going
to turn out now another idea that we
talked about frequently is so you see
whatever you know doctors probably have
another idea about that we look at
things very mathematical in the sense
that we have no forward model in
medicine we cannot say you have this and
and we predict that in 14 days you will
certainly have this we have scores we
have probabilities we have time series
we have you know we have Swiss three and
Munich REE but we have no forward model
we cannot actually predict anything with
certainty so what can we do you know
it's eric topples book starts with a
quote from Kierkegaard we have to live
our life forwards but unfortunately we
only understand it's partly backwards
and so we have to go back actually
retrospectively
and gather a lot of information and then
try to make cohorts of people which we
call digital twins actually
doppelgangers would be better than a
twin I think but you basically you know
we've done it with our Harvard team so
we have an embedded team at Harvard
University at the medical school I did
that for Aetna so they created so these
computational phenotypes and made how
many cohorts and twin pairs 56,000 twin
pairs so you can see actually these are
people in these cohorts with that risk
analysis
what is the idea for a cohort the idea
for a cohort is to have a delta of
normality because we don't know what
normality is so that's why we can't make
a forward model and we can't we don't
know how one cohort translates into the
other we know about symptoms and
syndromes and the Charlson index but
these are all basically very medieval
statistics so more and more we are going
into that digital twin thing with the
pairs every pair now wants to set up
these cohorts to understand the
population better and in the end and I
think a decennial from now perhaps we
will come to the patient in silico with
a sort of a more forward model but for
the moment this is not yet there another
thing that we have recently done is so
we are launching a micro satellites
a micro satellite is a satellite at 450
kilos and you basically launch it you
know you can launch it with a cannon and
the Army has a lot of cannons they don't
use because now it's all about drones so
and what does he satellites do well you
they they have hyperspectral cameras and
they have like 10 to 20 bands and you
can label the bands and so you can see a
pollution which is a burden on the
genome you can also see social
demographics around it and and you can
also see where the food is and and I
think it will be important to actually
for bio meteorology biometry Lachie is
actually the weather conditions plus the
pollution combined with your disease so
some people should probably live
somewhere else and when they are living
now yeah I'm so I am a firm believer
that the intelligence is in pictures and
not in language and if we can avoid
natural language we should certainly do
it because it's far too ambiguous
and also I like I like you to think of
the idea of your smartphone your
smartphone is actually a spectrometer in
our camera so the feature in the
smartphone became the product you are
using your smartphone more for as a
camera as a spectrometer then actually
as a phone so why is this so important
why have we put all our our knowledge on
pictures and you know that the image
data set is 14 million pictures well it
is because I think the Egyptians were
right it's all about the Sun so if you
put a cell under the Sun it's very soon
it will capture the most intensity of
the Sun which is between 319 and 700
nanometers and actually evolved very
sophisticated cameras encoders and
decoders of that sunlight so there is
reason to believe that the with the
several extinctions eyes were extinct
but they developed again so it means
that they are a survival necessity and
most of our intelligence is built into
picture recognition so more CNN than RNN
so just to give you an idea so in in
that in that image said dataset was my
niece was then three years old and so I
calculated actually so the image data
set is 14 million but if I calculate my
niece who was then three years old and
how many pictures that she has trained
her neural net with that is a hundred
times more than image net and she's only
three she was only three years old so
I'm taking 24 frames per second because
it's the secret formula of Disney all
the cartoons are for kids are on 24
frames per second we can theoretically
go 2,000 frames per second especially in
dramatic circumstances but we normally
go from 40 to 60
the really enticing and enthralling and
mesmerizing thing happens at 24 frames
per second so that little girl already
trained ourselves and our brain and our
intelligence with more pictures than
imagenet had at that point so we have in
order for this planet to work we need a
massive labeling effort and so we have
built software now which is already on
the App Store and so that people can
label themselves it's just like you know
taking pictures and then putting all
these pictures together and getting to
know more about the world another thing
that we've been working on is a social
mobile genetics it's actually very fun
we have we parse actually your complete
the genome we open up your GPS and then
you can find people like you you know
and which can be very interesting for if
you want an organ donor so you can find
them you know in a new social organ
donor Network but it can also be you
know most people actually choose their
partner because of they have a know
because the partner has a distinct
immune system from from their immune
system you know h late too and so that
also you can find with that so we're
thinking in Silicon Valley now to
organize genetic parties where we can
try this thing out because we have to
take the stigma away from genetics that
it is a destiny because it is not it's
not a you know it's not destiny we can
change a lot but we just have to know
where to start well we're also been
talking to you know a lot of bankers in
a in in Wall Street who are thinking
about that that health care should be
just like any other quartile or credit
or trying or insurance you know airline
you know the economy would be just a
reactive you know Economy Plus will be
more active and business with that be
proactive
and first class would be live extension
which then coupled with your live
extension and so they are thinking of
making several you know insurances ready
for this based on life insurance I don't
know if you know it but life insurance
and health insurance are dating for the
moment they're having big meetings to
put their metrics together which makes
sense because for life insurance it's
okay to be sick you just cannot die
otherwise we have to pay you back and
for health insurance you can you can not
be sick but if you're sick it's okay to
die as soon as possible because
otherwise has also raised up money
so putting these two metrics together
you get a cradle-to-grave
a journey of a patient which again
translates into the retrospective and
prospective and the forward models i we
believe a very you know they're it's
unstoppable the bandwagon of the
consumer as has already left and the
seller's market will become a buyers
market and people will repent you know
and they will convert their dark souls
into you know the fallen angels will go
back to tell you something about live
data as a latent economic asset so i
have a small video to show you know that
didn't work you were unique when your
genetic codes carried out and created
you you are the medical hub of all your
life data but where is your data now
it's all over the place your life data
evolves and is used every day for
results and profits you never see
imagine if you could bring all your life
data into one secure place simply
collect them from different sources log
in with your email and password is all
it takes to put your health in your
hands in one click
from your lab tests and medical records
to how the environment influences your
health it's all there with dr. I the
evolution of your life data has
unprecedented value by connecting your
omics data in a structured way you
unlock your own predictive health
insights here you can also join crowd
back research that's what we call data
trials contribute to science and earn
financial rewards by helping humanity
when the shared data leaves your phone
it is encrypted shredded into thousands
of pieces stored over hundreds of
decentralized notes using blockchain
technology data is used to build
predictive models and accessible only to
verified and validated data scientists
for a limited time the models are
trained by the network and shared back
to you
what's even better you could make
monthly income by doing so it's about
having all your health at hand to do
whatever you want and you possibly can
value your health join the health
evolution so I think more and more
people will realize that health data is
becoming a flourishing marketplace we
have to try the doubt
so we have already the marketplace and
people when they contribute health data
they can buy stuff on Amazon or Walmart
is also a partner lyft is now a partner
so it's it's you know while instead of
surfing or or twittering they can make
make some money and actually also get
back their personalized results and I
believe that so everyone will be able to
actually now it's already possible with
our system that people will be able to
start their own clinical trial and it's
now being done by doctors doctors and
their patient organizations starting
their own trials or latest trial is an
interventional trial now with Stanford
Medical School which is the IRB and this
is about twenty-six antiepileptic drugs
and with a cocktail of three where the
therapeutic window closes at three so
it's a permutation of 15,600 which
exceeds the mental capabilities of the
new
so see how the machine can help them I
think more drugs will be approved by the
FDA in the next two years and in the
previous decade for several reasons
first of all there's 46 drugs that are
going to the patents are going to expire
in the next two to three years rare
diseases or there are more orphan
diseases clearances than ever before and
so the CR owes have a kegger of 6% the
pharmaceutical companies are getting
ready to do get a lot of biotech trading
in but more importantly as we have done
in the banking industry with money we
are actually moving the filter from
before to behind so we're letting more
and more experiments in the market so
this actually explodes the economic
activity and at the end we regulate and
we do a lot of observations so which is
now called the real world and although
we call it the real world
apparently this real world is getting
more and more synthetic because so we
became last week we said yes to one of
the partners of RCT duplicates together
with Harvard and Bryan Bryan Women's
Hospital and Ethier so our job is you
take 30 closed you know a 30 finished
randomised trials then you go and look
at the synthetics you know in medical
records you know in you can do claims
and building activities product and
disease registries electronic health
data from social media people cohort
studies patient generated data and we
are going to actually try to prove that
the gold standard is actually no longer
the gold standard because we now have
access to all that data and I think I
don't know if we will arrive at the same
but we will certainly arrived at the
erosion of the randomized trial and
doing a way of placebo fear because we
are using the real world as a synthetic
arm it is very very strange
also the world the fact that real world
the world was invented in Palo Alto
which is scientifically correct because
we have no idea how the real world
actually works
so a lot of my clients are payers and
pharma and they always ask me like how
do you start with AI we want to start
with AI in our company and where should
we start
and so I normally go with to the ship of
theseus the ship of theseus is a thought
experiment then is you know when is the
ship of theseus no longer the ship of
theseus if every every year you actually
change one board you know after you know
like 50 years it's no longer the ship of
theseus because you have changed
everything because they see in large
corporations there is always there is
always time to correct but there is
never time to do it right
well my what we have done for anthem for
you know we are now at day 264 we have
made it into you know I my philosophy is
from the moment you change the first
board in your ship you are actually
changing the ship of theseus and it
actually spreads virally into the
organization so now we have made anthem
into you know more but of course our
real mandate is this you know completely
nuclear and drones are everything
time to tell you something about AI and
what we are doing in AI and so we are
using many many tools but we are mostly
indebted to Google we are using
tensorflow but we are making our own
proprietary modules on tons of floats
some of of them are used by Google
themselves so you know that machine
learning the the big thing is that
machines you know we used to as coders
we used to write every line of code you
know we might have stolen a couple of
things from github but yeah we have to
really write all the lines of code and
machine learning came and that was
really magical because
basically in goes the input and in goes
the output and out comes the algorithm
we don't have to write it anymore but of
course there's a lot of labeling to be
done so deep learning comes with deep
learning you can do you can you can make
like millions of more of data and but
therefore you need the cloud so then you
have to transfer the information to the
cloud and that's also a problem because
then you have upon all these constraints
so each learning is a far better so we
did that learning for the first time in
2017 and on every phone now and on every
phone we just put all the intelligence
on the phone itself it doesn't have to
go to to the cloud and I'll show you an
example of that and then the next step
is federated learning that is basically
the crowd replaces the cloud in the
sense that you every phone is actually a
node in a system and that system works
together and it's a bit like Kickstarter
but for you know people who are now so
this is a our client in China and so
they don't have a nut so they are in
Hong Kong they are a big life insurance
company and so they don't have a network
in mainland and so what we made for them
is we chase 5 million faces through
through an AI module and it works like
this so this is one of our engineers by
the way we do everything in-house it
gets your age sex height weight
immediately life expectancy and of
course also immediately your life
insurance premium just from a selfie and
then they just click and you know and we
are pushing that argument further and
now we are putting it on so for a an
American client we are putting it on a
big healthy health a telehealth platform
so that so the doctor sees you know
when the patient is nervous or when he
might not tell the truth or when he's in
a because especially for psychiatrists
and psychologists when they are in front
of a screen they argue that they are
losing the enriched environment
another thing passive collection will
create by a parallel extensional
existential dimensions on demand so
we're talking a lot about this in
Silicon Valley now and I urge you all to
look at black mirror the Junipero
episode and so basically if you take 5g
and you take the neural Nets now and you
take micro processors and you put that
all together what do you get well you
get a very cheap microprocessor where
you can put a coin cell battery in which
is okay for a year and we keep streaming
data because it's in mesh you get a
complete pixelization of environments
which you can sell or they can sell you
know like now algorithms also sell to
algorithms they don't need us anymore as
consumers so the the interesting part is
that neural nets are compute bounce so
what does that mean well basically they
only multiply matrixes you know they
only take like two two cached numbers
and they multiply it so very very small
amount of memory needed so no display
needed small antennas needed so these
micro processors could could cost $0.50
and with 5g they would have an enormous
possibility of shooting all that data so
where we want it to be you know I can
imagine now if you just take uber and
you put a camera well you can sell all
that data to for instance grand theft
auto you know and then you can do grand
theft auto in your own village so I
believe that not only the world of the
future will not be exponential I believe
that it will be it will be factorial you
know and exclamation mark there's a
little bit as a big difference at the
end it's not sort of the same because I
we are in for a period where we won't
experience what 100 years of progress
anymore but probably twenty twenty
thousand years of progress like if we if
we now think that our children don't
understand those anymore and vice versa
so their children will certainly not
understand them anymore of course we
will also generation B beta which will
be born in 2020 will also probably
already be edited privacy is
unsustainable so we now have a
sufficiently advanced technology
indistinguishable from magic
which is basically tensor based so we
are instead of bringing the data to the
models we actually bring the model to
the data how does this work well like
this form for one of our clients anthem
is we are using federated cloud learning
we are bringing it out the 10th of June
it's on iOS and Android will follow just
suppose that you are a pharma company
and you just have your you did a trial
you have your covariance you know you
know age gender
disease BMI you know all your covariance
and then you have your performance
characteristics of that trial and that's
expressed in tensors so what we say is
give me your covariance we go into the
anthem database we look at the
covariance probably we have hundreds of
thousands of people like that we do the
same we run the same trial we give you
our tensors or we
and globalized your tenses with our
dancers and so instead of a thousand
people to go to the FDA you have the
real world attachment as a synthetic arm
with 200,000 people more which would get
you easier to the FDA we believe this is
going to be a very big you know a
billion-dollar industry
and this will then give rise to a
derivatives marketplace for real world
data in 2020 were so basically we will
exchange tensors it's what we did in
banking with derivatives you know there
was at some point we thought there is
not money supply enough you everyone
keeps this money so let's create
derivatives the same will now happen in
in insurance and with that that will
reflect on on medicine but is also
nonlinear clinical trials will warp
drive real world so we have a also a new
product for June 10 where basically you
take ten thousand ten thousand patients
that can enter your clinical trial but
from and they don't have you don't have
to wait until these ten thousand
patients have have all put in their
their data so you just actually the
trial starts to learn from a patient one
and in real time actually gives you the
control functions and and the
performance and if you want to stop at
two thousand you just stop the trial
training without a central authority is
also possible now that means that people
can set up their own trials or we know
we now have a person who wants to set up
a trial on tinnitus so he says I have
tinnitus I go everywhere nobody said I
have it - I don't know what to do
well that's let's all get together it
doesn't cost anything I'll launch it
from my phone my phone actually works as
a server for all you guys so I get your
gradients and then you know it goes into
another another server which is a
transient server
and we call it no where instead of
software and that transient software
globalizes all the tensors and we get
actually you know updated updated
gradients back I also believe that data
science for physicians will be huge
success we did the first tryout on with
Berkeley and so we gave a course based
on chromosomes so chromosome one was of
course the the biggest course is ten
percent of the genome and so we showed
doctors like these are all the diseases
that lie on chromosome one and then how
you can actually give advice to your
patients about that it was a big success
it made us actually take over a company
called Kressel which we then together
with Google completely reformatted it so
that doctors don't have to do anything
computational anymore so they don't have
to put in any you know it's just credit
cards and it cost almost nothing and
they have access to GPUs they can drop
data they can work on the names database
and so they can do it for their own
research or their for their patients and
I think China might teaches a couple of
tricks we learned a couple of tricks
from China why because there is nothing
so they have to basically reinvent
medicine and they sometimes reinvented
in in interesting ways for instance they
have like this circle you know and you
put it in you know it's Wi-Fi and in
that circle you know there are several
pictures it's your pharmacist your
doctor or hospital or your insurer your
click and you talking I thought it was
very interesting you know like getting
people immediately Virtual Assistants
that's something we did also for a
client that's so the problem for that
client is if they insure a hundred
million American lives there are also
there are always people have to go to a
retirement home but when we know when
it's too late
so what we have to do is we have to know
it three to six months in advance so we
actually predict based on falling
osteoporosis and and a lot of other
things in the back we predict when they
will have to go to a retirement home and
then we have a big demand and then we
sell that demand and then because
otherwise for three months they will end
up in a hospital at five thousand
dollars a night so to conclude what we
actually talked about in Silicon Valley
is how can we help doctors well first of
all we have to take the record-keeping
away from doctors because you know they
were not trained to be accountants that
you know that didn't sign up for that
also taking the collection of data away
from from them taking the educational
burden away from doctors by educating
the patient more taking the
quantification burden away by
introducing AI but more importantly
keeping known patients away from doctors
and in our survey this is one of the
biggest ones because you see we are
there is a cataclysmic event coming up
at us it's called global graying so we
all get old you know by 2025 1.5 billion
people will be more than 65 fertility
rates are going down the average age in
2025 will be 40 years old so our planet
is losing neurons by the trillions
luckily we have machines we'll put these
new tricks in but so the problem is
everyone wants to talk about this
everyone's to talk about you know their
disease wants to talk about what happens
when I die you know I have cancer and
actually that could be done by other
people no it used to be done by the
church so you know we now have a 3.7
trillion debt
mostly because there are no priests
anymore where you could go for free and
talk about these things and they would
connect you to the divine now in Silicon
Valley we've been thinking a lot about
this and there is even a
new the benevolent order of the cyber
banks and but we have to bring religion
back but it cannot be as religion
because it's a legacy concept so we
believe that religion can come back as
mindfulness because mindfulness is a
very interesting concept it's it also
promotes peace it promotes collaboration
it promotes thinking about the essence
of life it tells you about brain science
it tells you about dying and so we
recently you know a couple of weeks ago
we we made a presentation home what
would be you know because if we are
going to write something for mindfulness
it can't be another Bible in text it
must just be a video and a video and how
can we make that concept known to people
that they understand what we mean and so
you know this is what we made of it
Oh some latency just
[Music]
there's one thing we cherish above all
else one thing which we get but one
chance it's the one thing we work for
strive for and fight for there is one
thing where the significance of our
belongings simply fade away it's the one
thing that makes us seize the day jump
for joy not waste but a single moment
there is one thing which is so simple
yet so complex one thing which we cannot
measure nor ever complete the picture
too
there is one thing which we say we're
all in this together one thing we will
always seek to make better one thing we
will always seek to improve it's one
thing we call life it can be here today
and gone tomorrow it's somehow it's
infinite in everlasting understanding
and is what we do start but now several
groups in Silicon Valley are working on
that new concept how can we help people
actually that are known patients but
they are going as patients to doctors
and so the Chinese have found something
about it they are actually they just you
know one of the big companies bought a
medical school and they are going to do
physicians which is only 30 months of
study and they can only do it's bit like
general practitioners and then MDS is
you know you know there are seven years
and then MD PhDs are then actually the
specialist asourian an MD PhDs they
created in four because they need for
the FIR you know they need that first
order you know of people to talk to
other people and basically that was my
presentation I thank you very much for
having listened to one of our crazy
ideas thank you
it's really fantastic really very
interesting and I would have never
expected we would have started with the
discussion of data and ended with a
discussion of religion very very very
thoughtful broking so if maybe we have
time for a question or two if anybody
has any thoughts or comments actually
maybe I'll I do have a question and it
has to do with this this this question
of the the data market and who
eventually becomes empowered because on
one hand we were you know you were you
were discussing the individual and
putting data at the ownership you know
for the ownership in the individual and
there's a trend you know you mentioned
some states that now are passing
legislation around data ownership but on
the other hand we we have to talk about
large companies whether it's insurance
companies like anthem or IT companies
like Google Apple etc that are also very
interested in this you know without
leading the witness I'd love your
perspective on you know is that a
struggle between the individual and the
company yeah I think it will be for a
while but not for long I think from
three to five years because more and
more we will keep everything on the edge
which is on our phone and that means
that we will have the ownership of the
real-time data and if somebody has data
of three to five months old about my
medical situation basically don't care
you know it's not worth anything anymore
there is a shelf there is also a shelf
near call it shall of time or expiration
time of that data and I think so you see
there is a lot of data around but a lot
of this data is no easy data
curated data that is
well-timed and well will of course be
worth more than others but of course you
know like large corporations are evil
otherwise they would never say that they
are not evil so but and but I think they
have no other solution now to jump on
the bandwagon of the consumer because
it's if they don't do it there they're
over basically and they have to rebrand
themselves you know Zuko burn tries to
do you know like now and it was a long
time coming but most boards had thought
that it was going to be longer than you
know after their retirement and mine
might be just in time
you know we're ready for a new
generation I think just a quick thought
I was amazing
talk this this concept of the rate of
change increasing seems to be prevalent
in every area of our society but it
seems like the human species doesn't
have the necessary the capacity to
absorb the rate of change that we're
setting up for ourselves through our
technologies how do you see that what
are some of the risks and opportunities
there to address them I think so if you
are now not into learning every day yeah
you will go behind that's why I'm a firm
advocate that children should have an
update program on their iPhone and
parents should have an old iPhone so
they should actually reverse it and and
I also get a lot of popularity with kids
when I say that and but you see if and
you know I joke with my wife when she
says I never go to the gym I said well
you know I was trained that we are half
animal and half god I prefer to train
the crowd but the animal but I think
learning and learning a new skill it can
be so invigorating you know like so for
instance a reading a mathematical
article it takes
you know it takes a long time before I
understand I have like young kids who
made their PhD at 19 who can do it a lot
easier than but when I've done it I
don't have to learn it by heart I can
tell it 1/2 drunk in a bar even you know
if I can go through the motions so I
think learning is such a great
experience and part of of life so and of
course we have to put a lot of in in
there this is not meant to do all that
learning and but if we don't do it very
soon we will actually ask a machine who
will translate to us in baby-talk what
the world is about and I try to you know
keep up thank you for your talk I really
enjoyed it there were a couple of times
that you mentioned clinical trials and
putting them enabling individuals or
patients to create their own clinical
trials and I was wondering how that
would happen because I know there's a
lot of legal there are a lot of legal
and regulatory activities that happen in
order to set up a clinical trial so how
could that happen for the individual or
the layperson
well I actually it's a so it took us a
while before we found actually a good
navigation and so we asked the IRB of
Stanford but that was really not good
advice and because you have to simplify
the process not not actually actually
complicated so with us it's simply there
is a list of IR beasts which they can
click you know they are online IR beasts
and there is also a list of PI's who
would like to do the P I for free if
they can publish about it and so they
have a P I they have an IRB you know
they they come together or mostly it's
in zoom actually they try to make the
protocol then you know it comes back a
couple of times it's also a learning
experience
and the fact that doctors are so
interested in it actually gives me a lot
of hope for the future I think although
I recently talked to a professor I will
not name but he said oh my god all these
doctors are going to start publishing
articles based on our studio and it's
okay you know like because we should
have more noise otherwise we can't have
more signals
you